as we continue to mark the loss of one
million lives to covet in this country
we are taking a look back at one
broadway star's incredible but
ultimately unsuccessful fight to beat
this virus
nick cordero is his name he got sick
with the covet in march 2020. that was
at the height of the pandemic's first
wave remember those days his way his
wife rather amanda klutz shared his
fight publicly for months with us she
even appeared here on cbs mornings
sharing the updates sadly nick died
after a courageous four-month battle
nearly two years after nick's death our
lead national correspondent david bagnow
visited his friend amanda at home in
california to find out how she and her
young son there's elvis how they're
doing
hi david elvis and mom
thanks for having us to your house again
oh my god of course
a lot of cameras
for the last 22 months nick cordero's
song live your life has become a sort of
anthem for his widow amanda cloose
[Music]
i've got the song stuck in my head
during nick's fight people around the
world joined in to sing that song
it became the title of amanda's book
which is now being made into a movie
and over the last nearly two years she
has embraced the idea of living her life
even as she grieves i love creating i
love staying busy i don't idle well
david
last year amanda joined cbs's the talk
as a co-host
that's where she and i first connected i
love you
love you too break a leg and i got a
chance to learn her story
to some it may seem like amanda's got it
all together what's your name
and maybe has even moved on from the
tragedy that thrust her into the public
eye we sometimes look at happy people
and we think are they happy all the time
but when you slow down and when it gets
quiet what are the things that
get to you for me it's not even when i
like slow down right now for me grief
it it'll hit me at a ton of bricks out
of nowhere for instance i i went to a
show last night i got home and i was
pulling into the driveway and a song
from journey came on that
nick sang in rock of ages
and i just i looked over at you know the
passenger seat and it was empty
and it hits you like a ton of bricks
and then you know you have to like go
into the house and it's and it's all
fine but like it's those moments where
you're just like
what happened
and and then it hits you you're alone
i'm alone i'm all alone i lost him
sweet little elvis was just a year old
when his dad died due to covert
complications well i won't call no cop
naked amanda met in new york city they
were both performing in the show bullets
over broadway he was the lead she was in
the ensemble i remember thinking oh no i
like this guy
and then i was done i was done for
knocking this down just as the pandemic
was taking hold across the country
they moved from new york to los angeles
it was around then mid-march when nick
started feeling sick i watched him walk
into cedars-sinai hospital and he never
he never came out
and thereby your journey of really
sharing with the world what was
happening started i just finished my
daily visit amanda began sharing updates
about nick's health on social media and
here on cbs mornings he's fighting i see
it every day give us some of the tick
tocks of what you told people oh my gosh
um well he went on a ventilator you know
went into a medically induced coma
he got sepsis his heart stopped he had
his right leg amputated that was like
the first couple weeks nick died in july
2020 and it was an alarm bell for many
americans a healthy young man with no
pre-existing conditions
dying as a result of the virus i miss
having somebody to come home to and i
miss laughing with somebody
every time
i retell this story
it's amazing how helpful it is in this
grieving journey really grief does not
stop
loss
death it does not
end you know there's no oh it's been a
year you must be better right right you
must have you cried it out you know that
is so not the case she'll tell you being
so open about her life hasn't always
been easy you had some people who sort
of came after you and were critical and
felt like you know in the book you
divulged things like being allowed to
visit him and they thought that you know
you had sort of overlooked this
privilege that you had
how did you how did you take that
you know i listen in life people are
going to come at you at all angles for
anything you do you know i mean
they came at me when i said i started
dating again everybody you know had
their opinions i just kind of let those
things roll off my back because what i
would like to say to those people is if
you could have lived with me for those
95 days
you would never ever
say what you just said to me
so that's how i
think about it uh i must have missed the
breaking news you've been dating oh no
it's not breaking i missed that post
so have you been on a date
i have dated yes yes yeah how did that
go
i mean yeah that's you know listen i
past tense or current um i'm not
currently dating anyone no
i want to love again i want to have
another person in my life i want elvis
to have a father figure in his life
you know you're not taking the place of
nick it's not ever that it's just that
nick was a part of my life
as elvis gets older and life keeps
moving on
amanda told us before we left somewhat
emphatically
nick will always be a part of it it just
occurred to me there must be a moment
where you have said out loud
thank you nick for this or thank you
nick for that oh every day there's
something about nick which has brought
about a lot of blessing in your life oh
so yeah oh a hundred percent
oh wow boy david amanda was always such
a sparkle during that time i think she
helped a lot of people when she shared
her story because you're right it was
such a wake-up call when nick got sick
because he was healthy we started
looking at this and went oh this is
really serious and when we lost him
after four months we also couldn't
believe that because i thought she
couldn't go through all this and not
come out on the other side so it's so
good to see her looking so happy and
that elvis is thriving and to know grief
does not stop grief is a living
breathing thing yeah
it it it doesn't end it's a headline
i'll remember from the story and to that
point i want to remind the audience
there was no vaccine when nick got sick
and following his death amanda is a
massive
vaccine advocate she's like david i
don't push it on people but i let
everybody know what i believe and she
said to me about love she said if if we
could have had the conversation in the
hospital she said i just know nick would
have said to me baby
love love again go find love
it's a beautiful celebration of his life
and we've got some video of david begna
with the hula hoop
the full tape hips don't lie how you
like that yes yes
we do hope she finds love again she's
quite a cat she is so lovely yeah i know
we all know that thank you david thank
you thank you
good to see her